فكره تجميع الكهرباء من الالواح الشمسيه
في الفضاء واعاده ارسالها الى الارض تعود
الى اكثر من قرن من الزمان لكنها كانت
مجرد خيال علمي واليوم تصبح واقعا
السعوديه وبريطانيا تعتزمان اطلاق مشروع
مشترك لانتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه النظيفه
في الفضاء الخارجي ومن ثم نقلها الى الارض
للاستفاده منها ذلك المشروع الطموح جدا
سيوفر مصدرا مستمرا للطاقه على مدار 24
ساعه يوميا دون انتاج اي مواد ملوثه
للبيئه
حسب التفاصيل التي كشفتها ديلي ميل
البريطانيه فان المشروع المشترك ستقوم
بتنفيذه شركه سبيسولر البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
طبعا الفكره انه راح يكون هناك مثل قمر
صناعي جيو ستيشنري يعني ثابت مع مدار
الارض
وهذا القمر الصناعي وهو ليس قمر صناعي
باسلوب التقليدي انما
مرا اجهزه تجمع اشعه الشمس
وحجمها اكبر من برج خليفه مرتين حجمها
هائل جدا هذا فقط في القطر في القطر
الدائري للي يجمع الشمس تجمع اشعه الشمس
ثم ترسلها الى الارض عن طريق اشعه
المايكرويف والى نقطه محدده
مساحتها تقريبا خمسه كيلو متر بحيث ان
تجمع اشعه المايكرويف وتعطي طاقه قدمها
اثنين جيجا والذي يغذي تقريبا
مليون ونصف بيت طبعا على حسب البيوت
البريطانيه والعيشه على حسب البيوت
وقد نفهم ايه اليوم عندما بنحكي عن
الالواح الشمسيه المجمعه من الشمس من
الفضاء كم المده الزمنيه اللي ممكن انه
تغطيها لفتره من الزمن هذا الشمس الماخوذه
من الفضاء
وايضا المساحه الجغرافيه التي يمكن ان
تغطيها
طبعا احنا نعرف ان عندنا مشكله المشكله ان
النصف الوقت عاده الالواح الشمسيه اللي
موجوده على الارض ظلام الليل فلذلك لا
تجمع بينما اللي موجود في السماء اللي راح
يكون في
القضاء الخارجي لن تحد اي مشاكل لا غيوم
ولا نهار عفوا الليل فلذلك سيجمع اشعه
الشمس باستمرار وتظل هذه الاشعه موجهه
تماما الى الارض على مساحه تقريبا خمسه
كيلو متر مربع فتجمع اشعه الشمس طبعا هي
الاشعه اللي جايه من القمر الصناعي هذا
راح تكون تقرير يعني مثل اشعه المايكرويف
لكن خفيفه جدا بحيث تكون منخفضه حتى اقل
من اشعه الشمس لكن لان عندنا طاقه عاليه
جدا او على مساحه كبيره فانستطيع ان نجمع
همم كهرباء اكثر